هذه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعتقلت 20
فلسطينيا من مناطق متفرقه في الضفه
الغربيه فجر اليوم نادي الاسير الفلسطيني
قال ان قوته الاحتلال شنت حمله مداهمات
واعتقالات واسعه في مدن عده بالضفه
الغربيه تركزت في مخيم الفوار جنوب مدينه
الخليل حيث انتقلت قوات الاحتلال 10
فلسطينيه
وقوات الاحتلال خلال الحمله وبهذا يرتفع
عدد المعتقلين الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه
العام الجاري الى اكثر من 200
و35 معتقلا
هذا هو طلبه 39 دوله اسرائيل في الامم
المتحده بالتراجع الفوريه عن الاجراءات
العقابيه التي اتخذتها ضد الفلسطينيين حول
الاستيطان وانتهاك اسرائيل المستمر لحقوق
الفلسطيني
انها ترفض الاجراءات الاسرائيليه العقربيه
التي جاءت ردا على طلب راي استشاريا من
محكمه العدل الدوليه حول الاستيطان
وانتهاك اسرائيل للمستمر لحق الفلسطينيين
وبشكل او ساعه ردانا على قرار للجمعيه
العامه واداعات الدول الاسرائيل للتراجع
عن هذه الاجراءات فورا
اكلت الدول الموقعه على البيان دعمها
الراسخه لمحكمه العدل الدوليه والي
القانون الدولي باعتباره حجر الزاويه
للنظام الدولي كما اكدت تمسكها بالنظام
متعدد الاطراف
الامين العام للامم المتحده
جدد رفضه لتعرض السلطه الفلسطينيه
لاجراءات الانتقاميه بعد موافقه الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده على طلب راي محكمه
العدل الدوليه بشان انتهاك اسرائيل قالت
مساعدته المتحدث باسم الامين العام
يحث على الامتناع عن اتخاذ مثل هذه
الخطوات الاحاديه
انه يلاحظ بقلق بالغ الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه الاخيره ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه
ويحفو الاطراف مره اخرى على الامتناع عن
الخطوات الاحاديه الجانب التي من شانها
تقويه الثقه بينهم والمسار نحو استئنا في
العمليات السياسيه وهو يضيف ايضا انه لا
ينبغي ان تتعرض السلطه الفلسطينيه لاي
اجراءات انتقاميه في ما يتعلق بمساله
محكمه العدل الدوليه
مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري وليد اذن
اسرائيل ترده بشكل سريع على طلب الدول
منها التوقف عن الاجراءات العقابيه بحق
الفلسطينيين
بالاستمرار بحمله الاعتقالات
استمرار بحملت الاعتقالات هذه اصبحت ليليه
20 فلسطينيه اعتقلتهم قوات الاحتلال
الليله وفجر هذا اليوم في انحاء المختلفه
من الضفه الغربيه لكن واضح من الموقف
الاسرائيلي سواء الميداني او على المستوى
السياسي كما عبر عنه سفيرها او مندوبها
لدى الامم المتحده انها لا تقيم وزنا
للامم المتحده وان كان ردها غاضب جدا من
ذلك اسرائيل التي اقيمت بموجب بقرار من
الامم المتحده لا تحترم الامم المتحده ولا
قراراتها وتدعمها في ذلك الى حد بعيده
ايضا بما يتعلق والشان الفلسطيني الولايات
المتحده بمعنى انهم لا يريدون من
الفلسطينيين ان يتوجهوا حتى الى الشرعيه
الدوليه من اجل الشكوى ولو الشكوى والبكوه
لذلك تاتي مثل هذه ردود الفعل الاسرائيليه
وهنا ياتي ايضا الاجراء الانتقام الذي قام
به اسرائيل واستهدف الخارجيه وزاره الخارج
الفلسطينيه خاصه كل الذين يعملون في اطار
نقل القضيه والشكاوى الى دائره همم
المؤسسات الدوليه اسرائيل لا تريد لا ان
يصدر عن الامم المتحده قرار بهذا الخصوص
ولا نقل الشكوى الفلسطينيه حول الاحتلال
المستمر على انه ضم وتعريف ماهيتهم من قبل
المحكمه العليا الدوليه لا تريد لذلك ان
يتم فمخططها خاصه مع قدوم الحكومه الحاليه
الحكومه مغاليه في تطرفها وتخفيض سقف
الفلسطينيين الى مستوى الحكم الذاتي في
الضفه الغربيه بمعنى ان السلطه الفلسطينيه
تتحول الى سلطه خدميه فقط دون اي انشطه
سياديه على غرار النشاط الدبلوماسي
السياسي في الخارج والحمله الميدانيه داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه تندرج في اطار ايضا
عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه مستمره منذ ابريل
نيسان الماضي يطلقون عليها كاسر الاموات
في اطارها قتلت اسرائيل دادا كبيرا من
الفلسطينيين ومنذ بدايه هذا العام هناك
هذا التصعيد الذي المرشح ايضا 14 شهيدا
واكثر من 235
معتقلا اخرهم 20 هذه هذه الليله وايضا
تنذر تحركات اقطاب الحكومه الحاليه تحقيق
تحديدا من الصهيونيه الدينيه المفرطه في
تطرفها والعنصريه الى جانب اوساط الركوديه
تنظر بان القادم قد يكون اكثر تصعيديه
وربما يدفع نحو الانفجار خاصه وان البعض
بدا يتحدث في اسرائيل عن ضروره العوده الى
اخلاء منطقه الخان الاحمر وكذلك من طاقه
مسافه وذلك لقتل حلل الدولتين على الارض
قبل ولادهتها شكرا لك وليد العمري مدير
مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله